so I got to do this since I've been
doing this but right now I know you know
well enough what's your question who
were you in this world I remember
somebody telling me your ego and or
arrives an hour before you do now you
know how to dance so you know how to you
know I just always wanted to be the most
defined massive person on stage but move
like smoke in the air the closest thing
to perfection of physique I've ever seen
as yours and magazines guys would say
derogatory things about you I would want
to go and hurt him and then I was told I
would never be Dorian unless I'm bigger
did you have somebody you loved up to
embody Bill I hate to say this
I think the level of impact you can make
moving forward is going to be much
bigger than the impact you made so far
it doesn't matter because this man right
here has Olympia's and I don't so who
gives it down they all got to come into
my world to get better
Hanan crazy flex what you just said and
a sport this is my job it's nothing
that's altered my life greater than this
and I was built for this we got plenty
entrepreneurs we can evaluate this run
homie look what I become
[Music]
so today I have a special guest with me
possibly the most legendary bodybuilder
of all time that's a four-time Arnold
Classic champion
Arnold called them one the greatest
bodybuilders of all time Ronnie Coleman
Ronnie call me the king was an
eight-time champion said he is the
greatest bodybuilder of all time and I
want to read something to you before we
get started obviously if you don't
follow bodybuilding we've done five
bodybuilding interviews during yes
Ronnie Coleman Brandon Currie Phil Heath
and now flex wheeler with us but I want
to read something to you because a lot
of times when you compete your peers
don't like you but I just contacted Phil
heated I said Phil I got flex coming
here's know everyone we're doing this I
said I got flex coming in what are you
able to read to flex before we get
started so he says here's what you
should tell him because he probably
doesn't know this he says let him know
that he was the first bodybuilder other
than Arnold and Lou that I followed as I
saw him on ESPN and became a fan I think
this was when you and Mike might tell us
oh we're doing stuff back in the days
mm-hmm he also doesn't know this but
back in 2005 he bought me a lunch after
prejudging at the NPC Junior Nationals
while I only had 26 dollars to my name I
have read his book flexibility multiple
times and throughout the years he has
always shot me advice straight when
others didn't he's a legend and I'm
privileged to say I know flex wheeler
the man not just the bodybuilder brother
you are loved by everybody in your world
and I appreciate you for making the time
to come out here and being a guest with
us Wow
makes it difficult to get started with
that but thank you so much it's not to
be here and Wow coming from fuel
actually I do remember that now a
phenomenal guy and done amazing but uh
yeah I think that's that's what
everybody want right regardless of
whether you're black white gray antennas
coming out of your head just to be
accepted for who you are as a person I I
think that's what all people strive to
have so yeah and that's beautiful
I gotta take some later on and send them
some money for that I think you did
you've got him lunch back in the days
but you know
but it's not just him dough Ronnie says
it about you he says it about you don't
door I mean everybody says it about you
for the kind of a character you weren't
obviously we got a lot of things to
cover with you here I'd like to go into
the current state of mr. Olympia I'd
like to go into what somebody like you
that's been around different decades so
you can kind of see this world of Joe
Weider time to then Arnold coming up and
starting his own Arnold Classic - now
where things are we'll get into some of
that stuff but I want to kind of go back
a little bit because I grew up a
following bodybuilding from the age of
13 14 when I came to the states and when
I joined the army I had all these
posters on obviously you have to be on
the wall because your physique is the
closest thing to perfection of physique
I've ever seen as yours I don't think
any physique is the closest to
perfection but everybody goes into
bodybuilding for different reasons I
know you know Fresno guy and there's a
lot of Armenian guys in Fresno so I had
a lot of friends in Fresno Bakersfield
all that but bodybuilding and martial
arts for some people go in because they
were bullied growing up because they had
a girl that's it oh my gosh
I like your muscles so it's like man I
want to get this compliment more to
reprove a point to a father figure or
somebody mom somebody in the family
different motives that they have what
was your motive to wanting to go into
bodybuilding and martial arts um two of
those when I was just brutally picked on
and bullied as a kid even though I was I
was a great fighter at a young age I
just I couldn't bring myself to hit
people on the street if we were in a
ring then you know it's combat and you
know a low combat it's nothing a lot
more any sport more than than martial
arts but it was odd actually me and
doctor Reeve we're talking about it I
when somebody hit me I would just let
him hit me cuz I would look at him and I
think wow if I kick him what if I what
if I brought their eye socket or what if
I broke their nose or I think like you
know maybe I'll just hit him in the
stomach but what if I miss and I break
their ribs so I'm thinking of hurting
them and not wanting to well they're
thinking of hurting me and wanting to
and I just I couldn't wire myself to hit
people on the street so actually one of
my tricks was was to invite the bully of
the school to my martial arts school and
I would he not laid him there and then
he would go back and tell everyone don't
fight
you know he knows so that's the way I
got around and then he held inept Coast
girls I mean I grew up in
back in the 80s weren't Britannia shirts
and with the matching bill absolutely I
mean so you got AB form so in 501 jeans
right that's that was our gear back
since it was those two things full yeah
it started so Fresno you're coming up in
Fresno obviously Fresno I don't know how
Fresno was during that time but I'm
assuming it's never best police rough
tough place all of that you know it's
kind of like back when it Crips and the
Bloods first started getting down so you
just had or so this is 80s colors yeah
so you got cousins and family members on
different blocks now at war killing
himself so it was it was interesting
times back then yeah no flex I watch
your videos you've been posting some of
these videos are you fighting and
obviously I went and looked at some of
the other I cannot believe how quick you
are like did you always have fast twitch
like you know it was it was through the
grace of just meeting an incredible
martial artist who's like a mentor to me
and a big brother his name is ty Maguire
and actually I was in police academy and
I met his business partner and his
business partner was telling me how
quick his feet were I'm like nah he
can't be faster than me so they invited
me to a school and and normally what
you'll do is you'll have whoever the
guest is fight one of your elite
students you'd sit back and watch how
good he is so not meaning to be
disrespectful I just ran through all of
this elite students and he kind of took
it you know ty kind of took it as
disrespectful so he said hey you know
he's very soft-spoken goes hey so I was
getting ready walkie doesn't know let's
uh you know let's let's move around a
little bit I'm like okay so I mean he
just touched me everywhere just lightly
just put here here here here hands just
barely so as an extreme fighter you
understand if they can just barely touch
you they could have knocked you out it's
a lot harder just to touch somebody to
throw it fast enough where they can't
see it only Wow and then pull back
before they hurt you so he just did and
it just say it just emotionally
distraught me cuz I mean I'm like you
know so I ran out of the place I was
nineteen I ran out of studio and we end
up becoming good friends and he goes you
know
I said why'd you do it he goes well you
can't just come in my school just just
run it through my students like that and
thinking that the teacher is going to be
the same that's like okay so I
understood that so it was from him I
didn't have a lot of money back then and
I got the school I was training that I
couldn't afford to train there and he's
I tell you what come to my school and
I'll pay for everything I'll pay for are
you a fight and all your gear and I
guarantee you'll be the number one
fighter in USA and one year and in six
months I was a number one fighter yeah
yeah so we just train I mean he would do
things like calling me like it three
o'clock the morning let's go train so me
I'm just worried I won't say no I might
not want to but I want to say no so we'd
go and kick up and down football fields
and stuff like that so yeah it was just
through him I was just there him of
pulling out the raw talent but like I
said it's there's nothing better than
moving around with a person or being
able to execute a technique that they
can't even see you know it's just it's
better than any drug I can ever imagine
so let me ask you how much senior is he
to you was it a generation senior where
you had some kind of respect for him
what do you get no no no no no no we we
it was tremendous respect and he
actually what I understood later on and
my fee acts he showed me tremendous
respect because most teachers would have
went on and knocked you out because you
just brutalize her students I mean sweep
and I'm stomping and stuff like that and
turn around and giggling and walk away
most you know they would take their very
offensive so he just touched me and he
would do things throughout my career
just one other you know short story is
um because I was the most advanced
student in school he would always you
know whatever technique he would
demonstrate on me and hurt you know I'd
be doubled over or crying or whatever so
but we're real close would hang out like
I said he was truly a father figure to
me and finally after a couple years I'm
like man taiga leaf boys why do you why
he always embarrassed me he goes what do
you mean you always embarrass me hit me
harder you make me fight you in front of
everybody and because you should know
better and he would never ask me for two
years he would never ask me and finally
I was in tears like why why do you do
this you know and he has looked at me
goes you should know better like oh no I
don't stop being philosophic
just tell me goes I want to put you
under so much pressure that if you ever
got in a fight you'd be able to handle
it because you've been there before
I was like damn can't you just say to
you guys nah wouldn't mean the same you
guys I just want to prepare you for life
so if you fight me and you can handle me
then you can handle anyone beneath me or
above me so I mean would gif is that
that's a tremendous group the others in
crow now this time you're 19 when you
first meet him how many years have you
been training martial arts yourself oh
my gosh I started when I was 9
after I seen the movie in it a dragon so
Bruce Lee was you know just looked up to
him and just I got it and when I seen in
into Dragon and I was that guy who got
bullied you know what I mean so from the
age of 9 I fought all the way till I won
the California Championship so I went to
California in 89 and then I wouldn't
fought that Sunday and won in California
and martial arts and they was Thai I
said you know which one do I do because
you do which one that shows you again
philosophical had something come on just
tell me goes which one you think told
you I'm like I don't know I'm good at
both right he goes yeah you are
he goes but bodybuilders tells you I go
how do you said he goes where you've
been doing this for X amount of years
you just started embody but don't look
how you accelerate he goes now I believe
that you will be ten times better as a
martial artist and you ever could be as
a bodybuilder but this would be enough
that I think you can beat any
bodybuilding champion that that you ever
lay your eyes on and he end up being
right about that so what I jerkily I
like to post those videos because
everybody kind of understands how good I
was as a bodybuilder when I'm like you
have no idea you know no idea you have
no idea but it's unfair watching you
like the other guys I mean you know I
have one of our guys his name is Chi hun
Alborz E he's 93 black bear on E a guy
in Iran he is a very very well known
he'd go to the Olympics all this up
night this he runs an office with us in
Orange County and I watch his kicks and
I see how fast he is at his age he's in
his 60s but then he shows videos from
back
there's any sequence I see your
quickness flex that's uh that's why I
wonder like did you play football
basketball with Sutton all that stuff
that all sucked him I was a late bloomer
so it was hard because my my he's not my
twin visa a year I think in like six
months older than me but he's just a
world-class athlete I mean he was a
fastest man in the valley when a West
Coast relays was in Fresno and 11th
grade he was beating grown men and on a
football field I just couldn't do not we
don't you know he was a running back got
a four-year scholarship to photos in
state so when you're in the shadow of
that you know what I mean you just don't
think you're any good so and plus I was
a late bloomer I was short I had big
feet you know trip over my feet when I'm
running and stuff like that so yeah but
martial arts is really fit for me and I
just fell in saying quote it you ever
thought about if you if you go that
direction where life would have gone I
mean let's let's just say you don't go
body woman yeah and you played that
everybody plays it in their mind what if
I what if I stay in a military because
for me was this course of staying a
military for 20 years I was about to
re-enlist what if I did I would gone out
three years ago what would life I've
looked at what I have gone and been a
sergeant major what would I have done
right where do you go when you go there
what does your mind I talked to him
about it and we was so close to this day
and the reason he had said that is is
back then it was very well known that if
you are a martial artist and you're in a
movie you would come out to a bunch of
flamboyant kicks and stuff like that to
establish a good you are and then a star
of the show knocks you out with one
punch so back then it was very
disrespectful to have someone who
couldn't fight but because there to star
the show just one punch that's stupid
punch no wanted you but yeah Telegraph's
right yeah and they knock you out and
that's it so and it was no movie there
was no money involved so yeah now I mean
it would have been great I mean I see
some of the great martial artists in
movies now and I'm like uh actually did
that stuff in a ring that they were
doing on set you know where the person
knows what they're about to do in his
choreographed I'm like you know I I did
that stuff fighting so but you can't go
back and what if what if what if what if
insane yeah yeah so what I understand is
is everything that I'd been through to
get to where I am now
helped me to be the person that I am
regardless whether it was good or bad
you take one of those away then it's a
la it's a table with four legs you take
one away now it's three it's not going
to be the same so I got to embrace all
of that and I do so so you're obviously
a big Bruce Lee guy I mean I try watch
read your stuff Bruce Lee Bruce Lee
everywhere mm-hmm so if Bruce Lee was on
the martial arts side who was that on
the bodybuilding side I don't know
because it's so subjective if we're
fighting and I do a technique and you
can't stop me you know there's no
argument about that right but if two
beautiful twin girls walked in their own
ladies right now it's about presence
right it's about presence so for
whatever reason maybe you're looking at
the girl on the right more and I'm
looking at the girl on left more so what
it is is that one has presence over the
other one so you don't even give the
other one a fair shake so it's kind of
like that on stage if you walk on stage
and you can just feel presence of a
person walking in a room they're already
winning because eyes are going to hit
them more so if I can still if it's five
of us on stage and we only have ten
minutes to display all of us and I still
seven seconds I mean sorry seven seconds
ten seconds and I still seven seconds of
that ten is not fair for the other four
people up there so it's about presence
also so the way I present myself or a
pose or maybe I smile or engage with the
crowd whatever all that's about presence
so it's subjective right because how can
you really say that's why you have some
people say oh so-and-so is a champion or
this person is a champion or this person
did best but if I if I do a technique
and I just knock you out that's not
about it it's not there's no question
about it since what most sports though
that are non-combat write Kobe's at best
now Michael joins the best not LeBrons
address it's subjective because they did
they're not gonna get down with each
other that way but in combat sports it's
different no I'm talking real combat
sports I'm not talking where it's set up
a fight and decide another I'm talking
in its true essence no it's an argument
in our did you have somebody you looked
up to in bodybuilding like was there
somebody where you said you know
everybody you know Michael Jordan's
David Thompson so Ronnie is Lee Haney
you look at some of these guys was there
anyone for you
yeah I mean I um so I you know I come
from a very humble background really
poor so my my gym that I trained in
didn't have many magazines so I wasn't
really brought up knowing who
bodybuilders were I heard of obviously
on a source a [ __ ] and I heard of Lee
Haney and then I heard his shine ray and
those were only bodybuilders I heard of
but because coming back from a martial
arts background I understood I can learn
from anyone so it doesn't have to be
somebody great it could be the guy in
gym next door to me that's training so I
just looked up in admire everybody who
accelerated in a sport and I would still
different parts from everyone it fits me
I'll take this part from this guy this
part from that guy so I just really
appreciate everybody who just really was
able to take it to a different level and
I just tried to emulate whatever I feel
that fit my reservoir and then I kind of
created my own personality and stuff
like that but I learned through the
history of other guys and watching them
when I competed against him who'd you
study the most anybody who studied I got
I hate to say this Sondre yeah a sunray
because wow the elegant way he posed
because we looked at as Buddhists on
stage right you know kind of like the
Incredible Hulk just mess and he was
very elegant on stage and I like that
because I came from a martial arts
background so he was one of the first
but then I learned who he learned from
which he learned from John Brown and
someone so I didn't start watching those
people compete and stuff like that and I
I just always wanted to be the most you
know define massive person on stage but
move like smoke in the air like a
ballerina on states that was always my
my goal this should look just ungodly
muscular but just be able to move just
so fluently and gracefully and stuff
like that so and yet and you did that
though I tried I try no you did that and
what I was always curious about you your
posing routines you you would have what
you would do exhibit
Ice Cube laughs if I can remember LL
Cool J you were corrupt you would do
all I'm like what do you know what is it
you know and you would haven't like a
remix go through a UN RMB guy or you
hip-hop or him everything so my logic to
that and it was a logic to it I'm if you
go to a rock concert turns in music come
on everybody goes nuts
nobody spent attention to nothing if you
go to a to listen to a symphony
everybody sits down and be quiet and
pays attention so I considered myself an
artist so that's why I the first we got
three minutes so the first two minutes
and thirty seconds I would have slowed
music because I want people to sit down
be quiet I want to display something for
you
but I know after a while that gets
boring just like a movie and movie you
can get take you through all these
different emotional but it has to bring
y'all on a up or also you walk away
disenchanted so I had to turn it up the
last 30 seconds to get people hyped mhm
and or else they'd be disenchanted you
know what I mean by just you know
falling asleep or whatever so that was
kind of my logic and I would always just
put picked a hottest song at the time
and back then that's it was you know it
was West Coast you know they're just
really banging out hits so I wanted
people to identify to the music as soon
as I heard the first beat which means
they get out a seat and they go crazy
so I mean you would see that you can see
that happen yeah so now you know how to
dance it you know how to you know well I
mean the way you looks like you know
like maybe two or three movements in and
that's it before people figured out but
no I just I'm uh I'm II I'm an introvert
so normally you know introverts or
extroverts when they're on stage you
know so I was very I was always
uncomfortable on stage I'm uncomfortable
in my skin but I learned at a young age
that people find out your weaknesses
they'll use them against you so if I
walk out on stage and I'm like then
people gonna dig deeper like what's
wrong to see us he decide this but if I
walk out confident and arrogant they
give me a once-over at the end um pay
attention kind of like if if I walked
into this building and it smelled great
but it didn't look really clean from the
smell of it I'm gonna relax I'm looking
around a little bit that's okay mm-hmm
but if the room really stunk but it was
spotless
I'm gonna continue look where is that so
that's the way it is on stage if you
confident people are going to give you a
once-over and they're gonna kind of
relax but if you up they're very
unconfident you look at yourself and you
they like yeah they're gonna stare you
down like okay you know what is it and
they'll start picking things apart so
that was kind of my my thought on that
whole thing especially in the world yarn
because in the world you're in you know
it's it like you said earlier subject
there versus you know Union your
underwear millions of people are all
that they're watching all that who are
you on stage with that set aside the
guys are on the greatest of all time
list not those guys the guys that never
won or the guys that were never even on
a classic chance I'm talking guys that
were that came in and they had
incredible presence but they didn't have
the physique was there anybody will you
looked and said disguise presents just
incredible why is he so confident
himself who were some of those I don't I
don't remember their names but it I
always admired them right because you
see a guy come out and maybe he wasn't
in great shape or maybe even his color
was off or something man he just had
such enthusiastic that it wins a crowd
Oh hmm you know and he'll start going
like this what I put in a crowd of start
clapping so that's that ability to
control the crowd and if you can do that
well enough and have an OK physique
you'll you'll get by and do pretty good
because you're selling yourself it's
it's not always about how good you're on
you're on stage it's it's a lot of it is
smoke and mirrors some how well can I
hide my weaknesses and you know how well
could I show off my strengths and in
doing so well nine times out of ten have
you fair out pretty well especially if
you like you said the opposite see a guy
just came out on stage and he was just
like ungodly unreal just a demigod but
he couldn't impose you know he'd do a
lot spread like this dope it doesn't
matter
he can't present himself so that's that
art I think that kind of left the sport
were you had to be able to present
yourself at a high level or it just
didn't matter when they judged us on our
performance and music and our color and
all that stuff it's kind of gone which I
think
you know a lot of us old-timers I even
remember Lila Bharata telling me goes
flex I'm not gonna go to show anymore he
goes why he goes you're retired he goes
it's just boring guys just go up there
and they just do stupid poses boring
it's not artistic like you know we used
to do it I'm like yeah you know you're
kind of right because it's a very
subjective sport right if you don't know
someone or have a family member or
friend of your training partner chances
are you know I can go to a bodybuilding
show you know it's not like basketball
or MMA you can just be completely
ignorant and sit there and enjoy it our
sport you got to kind of understand what
we're doing and understand it back on
why we did it and what we had to go
through to kind of really you know enjoy
that it's not just a visual sport where
you can just walk in and just sit there
kind of like golf
I can't watch golf but certain people
who play golf I'm interested in them so
all Lots it's kind of like that yeah
that's a good point tiger pulled me at
golf and research called whistle yes one
of the only guys I got the painting gone
there because of who Tiger was but since
you brought up the the bodybuilding side
presence wise out of all the guys who
competed against these are names that we
know who had the strongest presence on
stage Ronnie and Dorian yeah to me yeah
those are two people that uh I could
feel their presence standing next to me
and I didn't like it was very eerie you
know I felt very dominant against anyone
else and it didn't have to do what size
or anything like that so those would
probably did to people that thought I
that was very eerie if I'm if I'm
standing here and I'm looking straight
and I can feel and and see them in my
peripheral vision that's unnerving you
know I'm trying to block everybody out
you know so definitely but uh
out of those two of course remaining I
mean - so we gonna do you know what
you're gonna do you can you cannot work
the guy because he's just a mule he's
just gonna work work work and then I
mean he in my opinion he's the greatest
mr. Limpy of all times I don't think
anybody ever break that record and when
I say record I don't mean a number
somebody probably get eight and I don't
ever beat him you know they never beat
his all-time best look it's not gonna
don't think so I'm not gonna really not
gonna happen no one's gonna beat his
look nah not gonna happen
Wow you had him up here yeah what
suppose you
those those those pictures he looks like
oh I like this look when he was 15 or
whatever they year he was I don't know
what the rank was 1415 with two years
before he went to ninth and in first
mmm-hmm
the skinny and then the muscle the way
was set up is just but you guys have a
lot in common door for seek wise so
Ronnie and Dorian do you think presence
can be taught and learned or do you
think that's something that a person has
I think it's both you can have somebody
who's like a natural dancer they just
look at and they pick it up and then
it's kind of like in martial arts you
can have somebody who's just natural and
then you have people that I fear the
most our technicians they look at you
they break down everything you're doing
and they can emulate it or stop you
because they're very technical about
everything okay you know so me if I was
fighting myself I'd be like all right
his right leg is his superior leg his
right hand is his superior hand so if I
can nullify those two things I have a
better chance of beating them first is
someone who's just gonna fight me on my
mirror merits of speed and everything no
you can't it's it's different but if
you're sitting there watching me and you
break down my moves and I'm not gonna
say oh but there's there's there's you
know there's a number probably about ten
different moves I was really superior
and I knew I would make contact no
matter what so if you already understood
that and notified him now I'm gonna
fight it's gonna be a whole different
fight you know so it's the same thing on
stage you know I went to more against
anything with his training back on nine
tennis when I got started 2001 and we
went to San Francisco because 9/11
happened so we couldn't go to New York
or San Francisco one of my guys
classmates was a guy named Glen Hopkins
and Glen Hopkins was a Marvel guys to
work at Marvel and he did all this stuff
with spider-man just a big personality
guy I think his wife at the time was
this gonna sound strange his wife was a
remember the movie American Pie is it
American I'm the floors mom was his wife
so but this guy was flamboyant he had a
great personality I'm 21 years old at
the time I'm 22 years old at the time he
says I'm gonna teach you something
we're gonna play a game so
so it takes me to this coffee shop in
San Francisco we sit there he says okay
I want you to guess everyone's net worth
when they come in I said you want me to
guess what it's I want you to guess
people's net worth
that's what's not gonna do with anything
he says you're a financial adviser you
better be able to read their network I
said okay he says what do you think that
guy's worth I said a guy looks like he's
rich he says that guy's broke those the
watches got on it's fake those shoes are
$150 they get that guy's broker so
really how interesting miksa what do you
think this guy's work I said not a lot
how about this guy finally this guy
comes in shorts t-shirt just a regular
blue watch that said that guy's probably
worth twenty to thirty million dollars
so tell me why he says the watch he's
got on doesn't look like anything that's
a quarter-million dollar watch the
loafers he's got on that's $1,300 his
shirt is a regular shirt with a $4,500
shirt and shorts are $600 that guy's got
money we gotta talk to this guy and then
he would get up and he would go talk to
me how are you what's in my like your
loafers I noticed you were in this and
then he was a bum cart and then he would
go so he says you got a watch as a
financial adviser so in the bodybuilding
world because I don't know what you're
looking at right now right you look at
this room in a different way than I look
at a room and I look at him in a
different way then you look at the room
so when you walk into the bodybuilding
world and you're looking at each other's
body and you're scoping each other out
what are you looking at what our
bodybuilders looking at with their
competitors so first thing it's a
psych-out like even though me and Ronnie
were inseparable we're close he'd stay
at my house preparing for the Olympia
and so on and I've stayed at Dorian's
house would say both talked about when
it comes to going backstage I don't make
eye contact with you anymore not that
way I'll walk hey how you doing Bob
we'll sit but I'm not gonna look at you
and we're looking at a face blah blah
blah when you're not looking then I'll
glance over but I don't want you to know
that I'm looking because if I'm looking
at you then you obviously look good
so it's a psych-out other than that for
me it really didn't matter what you look
like backstage or getting ready for the
show
it's only about 45 minutes onstage that
matters so our nerves will just blow us
off I mean we you know retain sub-q
water within seconds to cut some nervous
system everything you trying to work
with the body and it we can't we're just
trying to manipulate
for X amount of hours so sometimes and
you you've seen this a person come on
stage and they look great and as a show
goes on 10 20 30 minutes they look
horrible so it never really bothered me
what a person looked like backstage is
what they look like on stage and how
they presented themselves because I've
been around a lot of great bodybuilders
who out look at in a gym and it would
just give me I'd be like how am I gonna
beat this guy one for instance is
probably let I mean tour a state park I
mean is my training partner my roommate
and I look how many gym I'm like what
I'm gonna do about this guy but when we
got on stage you know I could just flip
a switch and be a different person
and most of the time that was a reason
why there was a difference so none of
those really factors mean anything
backstage and if you are really good so
I was also too person that if you look
great or you're struggling I'm back
Viney rooting you on it's not me and you
it's not like a combat fight why knocked
you out and taunted you why you are
laying there bleeding you know that's
kind of insulting but it's a subjective
sport we got seven guys down there or
women who are picking who's the best I
didn't do nothing to you why should it
be mad at you that you won or lost why
should it be mad that you're doing good
they're gonna make that decision so just
like every man or woman up there on
stage they're trying to do like you
they're trying to make money to trying
to take care of himself make a living
why would you be pissed off that this
person beat you if you really want to be
a man about it
go down and talk to the judges why do
you disrespect this guy say he didn't
look good I sort of beat him yes a
coward is that common in your world it
is now not back in my okay it is it is
now you you read about and you hear a
lot of it for me
undermining their peers and all that
yeah yeah yeah it was going on a little
bit in my era but I never got caught up
in it you know people would say like you
know I'm how did you take it yet the
biceps yeah yeah or you're taking food
money off my table food off my table and
I'm like I didn't you might want to go
talk to the judges because they the one
who gave me to not not you so
I just never got caught up in that I
mean these people trying to do the same
thing I'm trying to do trying to make
money to take care of themselves why the
hell would you be pissed everybody I
always asked me um you know what did you
say to Ronnie when he won in 98 when you
whispered yeah yeah yeah he was my
friend
so I said man I love you congratulations
by the way I'm not gonna be at your
victory party tonight why in the hell
would I go sit down so what is man is
filling on top of that ain't a real
friend so I went back to my room and
hung out with my people and ate pizza
but why would I go there and hang out I
mean that's not cool so did you did you
have a flex did you have the mind set up
I want to be the greatest of all time
like was that you or what was your
mindset when you were competing because
so I I have clients in music I've
clients in business of clients in
Hollywood you know sports and all that
and it's very different one time I was
in the couple my clients in Hollywood
the sports side and they were talking
about their teammates this is Shawn Kemp
era if you remember Shawn yeah I did
Kendall Gill like all that air so we're
talking about all these other players I
said what is it like and he says you
know you got to realize in basketball
once you get in and you have game and
your starter you got parties you got
girls you got stuff that's happening
that makes no sense like you can go to
the mall and all of us and you're going
into the dressing room average man or
you know they don't experience these
kinds of things you're driving hey
what's up girl gets in the car you go
you know so the average guy who doesn't
have that experience cannot really
understand what it is to be you right
like you know when a when a girl is
drop-dead gorgeous and she was working
at the mall and she's 18 years old and
she doesn't yet know she's beautiful
fifty guys hit on on a daily basis
versus somebody else may not experience
that right so yeah so in basketball you
go in there you go in you're like okay
this was all this lime lights kind of
cool my new girl in high school that was
never interested she just call me so I
got together with her and her and her
and her all the ones that I could
because you know I'm not saying you're
thinking that way but you know I got
with this I got way
okay so what's left and then and then
it's I'm playing ball you know they know
who I am I'm on magazines I'm on you
know Sports Illustrated whatever on the
basketball side and then comes all-star
turnout got talent where I can compete
and then we got these cycle competitor
guys that like Kobe who they all like
your time at like a Utah mod Ronnie like
if he works like a mule you know guys
like that yeah who were you in this
world
so now answer your first question I
always had self-esteem problems always
had self-esteem problems so I never
believed in myself and anything as a
martial artist I fought terrified I
fought terrified and I wanted to I
always attacked because I didn't want to
know what you had to offer so I always
tried to attack my opponent and then I
tried to own them within the first 30
seconds so I can relax and then fight
better because when when you have me
unsure of myself I'm thinking so action
reaction time I'm already hit instead of
thinking about hitting you and
bodybuilding like I said I came across
very cocky arrogant because I was
terrified you know any of the videos you
watch when I tapped a person on the
stage next to me you know people looked
at that like wow look how arrogant he is
you know he's showing that he's better
no actually it wasn't it was I was
trying to do like a sleight of hands so
if you're looking at us and I'm
uncomfortable if I put my arm around
this guy
I just transferred all my energy to him
so now you're gonna look at him you're
not looking at me anymore and that was
my my my way of trying to do that but
saw was wired differently even though I
I didn't think I was good at it it
didn't stop me from just trying to kill
it in a gym most people would say okay
I'm not good I'm not gonna try hard I'd
be like I'm more or less of a realist I
don't think I'm not good but and then it
ain't gonna be because I didn't put
everything into it I don't think it's
gonna happen but I'm gonna go try anyway
we're most people like I'm not that good
at I'm not gonna try
you know so my work I love training you
know all we did is eat sleep and train I
didn't believe in video games are going
out or partying oh you didn't know no
you know we thought you were running
around with girls left and right
partying well not during training so not
doing training but unfortunately you
know they say that about athletes but I
jokingly say in it you know reverse it
out
yeah but we're sleeping with normal
people so there's two of us right so you
can't say the athletes are all bad
because they're not running around
sleeping with other athletes their sleep
notes so the common denominator is
people do that don't just own athletes
or somebody who has money or not because
people just do that so don't put it on
them but during training C's I not just
if we went out to a club which we talked
about before my buddies worked at a club
and I did for a while
I'd be like leaving by 11:00 so they
wouldn't even go with me anymore they're
like flex you got to drive by yourself
because they want to stay until 2:00 or
3:00 and I'm like I'm tired and I'm gone
I'm sleepy
so but other than that I just I wasn't
in a drinking smoke and anything if it
didn't better mean I to do certain
things that look the way I did so if it
didn't better my craft I wasn't about it
I'm just at all no you it's okay so so
you weren't a party animal guy no no you
know I don't I don't I don't know if it
was during my era or not because I
wasn't around my boys we didn't get on
like that me Chris Rico they would go
out and hang out you know to hit on
girls or whatever but that's it I mean
we just didn't go out all the time and
they went out a lot more than I did but
I just wasn't a type of guy remember I'm
insecure so I'm not gonna be at a club
shooting at girls
That's not me I'm not gonna walk up to a
girl and say hey you want to dance
because I'm fearfully getting turned
down who was the first person in your
life that's it flex who can be somebody
in your life his name was Joe Jennings
just a local bodybuilder from Fresno and
then a bigger name Jeff Lawson
you know I remembered I'm sending a why
he got great genetics and and in my
ignorance I'm likely we call me black is
that a derogatory I didn't know I didn't
know what that word yeah you know oh you
don't know what your nedick's meant no I
didn't know at all how old were you when
Joe Jennings said you've got a great
body
probably about 16 16 years old yeah
father-figure any men in your life that
was in con my yeah my dad was deep into
football and basketball he got a double
scholarship so my brother Donnell been
that you know he was an incredible
football player and track star it's kind
of a sport in school so everybody goes
to it right who's gonna go to a martial
arts tournament you know I mean the
school is there the school is supporting
so it's it's a big-time sport martial
arts isn't especially back then and then
when you got bodybuilding it's kind of
weird what are you doing where those
those underwear you know you got grease
I'm in my grandmother you know she goes
you look like a greased up pig you know
and our beautiful way of saying cuz she
just didn't understand the innocence yes
beautiful yeah I mean she was born in
1909 so but um yeah so I I just throw
everything into it but I was just
terrified man I mean if I went and
competed in Ironman or the Arno I'd be
like you guys got to come get me I own
this but I don't know why when it came
to Olympia light I'm just gonna go try
and you know I'll settle for a second I
just never I truly never believe that
can be first number one in the world
fear of failure fear of success hmm I
probably say both both because both can
be very damaging both can devastate you
I would say just fear because again I'm
insecure and a low self-esteem so it was
just a fear of um possibly being that
well I had a lot of pressure on me
already because how good I was I was
expected you know to look a certain way
and you know a lot of us believed I was
judged on my best not if I was better
than the other people on States so I
remember you know one time I took after
my car accident
I broke c5 and c6 and it's 94 yet 94 and
I came back and I competed and that
February after breaking c5 and c6 and I
I end up winning the Ironman and the
next weekend I went senior on that took
second and when I had to car accident
you know the company I was would I don't
want to be disrespectful but everybody
knows but while I was when I had to
accident while I was in a car
the hospital they fired me so you know
when I got home is you know a facsimile
there that you've been released from
your contract due to blah blah blah I'm
like I'm okay I'll be able to compete so
I baked you know for them to keep me on
City dance stated half my money that I
was making and I went up one two Ironman
and then I wanted the honor classic okay
see I mean I took second a owner classic
and uh it's like yeah yeah you know I I
won my first pro so after my breaking my
neck and you know then I took second
yeah Donny goes we'd expect you to do
that
you know we expect you to win look I
beat all these people who've been
healthy all year round and I come back
from this devastating accident and I was
that good he goes yeah but we expect
more from you know psych Wow
so it took a whole nother you know at
the Olympia for them to reinstate me
100% so you know it's like a
double-edged sword is kind of like all
great athletes and I'm not I'm not
calling myself great but you you look at
their best or a model you look at their
most beautiful or an actor or a singer
you know the best song and I measure to
that forever so one rare thing is I kind
of came close in a 90 percentile my my
second show ever
so it was nowhere but either down or a
little ways up from that so and I I just
like a biorhythm up and down so I was
always compared to that instead of
getting better and better and better you
know I came out what went on her class
went on called me that one of the best
body builds in history that was my
second Pro show ever
so you know and then I was told I would
never be dorian unless i'm bigger so I
was like what do you mean how do I do
that
you know so first you're saying I'm one
who said you can't be doing all what's
your but some church I don't even
remember it okay but I look back I know
is it a lot of people saying that like
was it the it was a size game back then
it changed over yeah I remember that I
remember when Dorian became the first
year yeah Axia was Nasr actually now
Suribachi
yeah yeah he was the first freak at 280
pounds on stage yeah and Momo
remember Momo Mohammed Ben Aziza who's
about five two and he way
like a hundred and ninety two hundred
ten pounds it was a lot of mass monsters
back but I think Dorian was the first in
our era to do that
and from then you're chasing whoever the
champion is and I think you know before
they judged you know how good you were
that's why a person like Frank Zane at
170 pounds can can be the best in the
world you know it became more of a size
thing I had a Sales Leader one time
telling me this and he made me really
think and he said because I'm getting in
I'm in the financial business and I'm
competing with these other guys and
obviously you've got a competitive
nature so you're kind of looking at
everybody and I looked at this guy
degree good market good background
parents together I'm looking at all this
stuff with them right and I'm like how
the hell do I beat this guy right man I
don't know if I can beat this guy or not
and then this guy sits me down and tells
me the most ridiculous thing and messes
with my head flex okay
he says Patrick let me give you where
your advantages I said tell me what it
is he says you don't have a market so
you have to learn how to prospect I said
okay he says you don't have a last name
so you have to make your last name you
don't have a degree so you have to read
the books you don't have says you don't
have you don't speak as good English as
the other guys so you have to improve he
says that guy is getting into this
business he's gonna beat you in the
first 24 months more than you are but in
the tenth year maybe it's not gonna
happen
would you say there was an aspect of the
game that it came way too easy to you
because you came in and you just I mean
you know you look at some of the
pictures flex it doesn't even make sense
look like now I think the greatest
picture ever taking in bodybuilding if
you ask me I mean it the greatest
picture ever taken in bodybuilding I
don't think there's a better picture
than this embody women I think this is
by far the greatest picture taking a
bodybuilding where you almost don't
think that this looks like a mythical
God like a Greek god from back in the
days that David is working on this - oh
thank you
and this is it right yeah Gary Phillips
a good friend of mine took
photo and I I wasn't even trying to pose
I was getting ready to hit my next pose
which is that what makes it a perfect
that's what makes it like perfection
because to me obviously this is a great
pose as well but flex I gotta tell you
to me
this is in a whole different league than
that one when you look at the physique
but going back to it how do you process
that question like do you think it was
you're your own person right because I
was very ignorant to the sport and a
history of it and how hard people had to
try to get there my first pro show was
against Vince Taylor and he was ranked
number 3 in the world and I beat him -
one point from being a perfect score so
in my mind I'm thinking ok this is a
fluke you know he's darling in for the
honor classic next week that's when he's
gonna you know so is he's a seasoned
veteran and I ended up competing against
him and Leela Bharata so I got number
Rank 2 in a world a number ranked 3 in
the world and I'd beat him both with a
perfect score and then I go to Germany
and France and I beat Vince again with
perfect scores so it did kind of happen
and easy and I just like okay desist
away it is you know why work harder or
why try to better yourself and 94 I
haven't had a car accident and it was a
challenge from the empathy I I agree
with you on all points including just my
pure ignorance of the sport and not
really just understanding the gravity of
been number one mr. Olympia I just I
didn't appeal to me I compete it based
on generating money I was poor I came
from welfare homes and all that so
relief I I just competed based on
generating money and I knew in certain
shows if whoever beat me before so if it
was Dorian or Ronnie if they was an
error I'm a wife everybody
hmm so I went to shows based on being
able to generate money if I had to run
into Dorian or to Ronnie then I'd look
at okay how much the second prize that's
worth it go in and shut that down at oh
and in second who was in your ear
because like was Joe in your ear was was
Joe Weider in your ear was there anybody
like that in your ear saying hey flex I
just want you know go talk to this guy
hey look spend some time with this guy I
need you to go over here was there
somebody kind of like course you know
kind of giving you the direction with
Dean Smith to Jordan or Phil to Jordan
have someone like that no because nobody
knew it I wasn't honest about it back
then
I remember I came across extremely
arrogant yeah you know my swag and it's
not I didn't know what that was but I
mean I I honestly created now understand
and I created this alter ego flexing the
other guy because man wheeler was wasn't
that guy you know so I didn't know it so
you you didn't think you had to give me
advice because I mean I'm just just
fully swagged out I remember somebody
telling me your ego and or arrives an
hour before you do because you're so
arrogant and it goes and when you walk
in a room we can just just share
arrogance and I I i understand that now
because when I watch any of my videos
I'll be talking I have to turn the
volume down I can't stand just such an
arrogant pompous you know so I can't
even listen to myself so I get it now
but it was all trying to hide the the
real person you know I called myself the
world's greatest chameleon so yeah so no
I didn't get advice like that because I
came across arrogant and like I had it
all so yeah yeah I I think I think in
that game like then in in the race car
you know this painting right here well
you see me standing and whispering
something in Tupac there a guy standing
right next museum is Ayrton Senna
to me it's the greatest racecar driver
of all time from Brazil I named my
daughter after his last name that's how
much I love this guy I mean I watch this
guy's document reflects I'm in tears I
have to watch about myself because I
cannot my kids see this thing Wow it's
very difficult for me to watch this
guy's documentary and my wife and I got
into debates to one a name my daughter
Senna and she said we can name our
daughter after a race car driver said
they forget about that for a second we
have the baby ten minutes baby shows up
doctors like we need to get the kid's
name I said I we don't have a name nurse
comes and I said nurse we got a name for
you Madison I give all the names I said
well you can't name in Madison because
the girl next door just named two kids
Madison my wife's like okay great and
then I said the Danica says you can't
name em Danica because I read a book
when I was younger and the main
character was very evil and her name was
Danica I wouldn't name her so how about
say no she says that sounds like a
flower
that's why we've got the name Sena but
in the documentary flex its he and
another guy named Prost and Prost knew
how to play politics and Senate didn't
auto play politics Senna was horrible at
it by the way Prost won five
championship Senna won three
there's no way Proust isn't Sina's
League it's no debate about it right
naturally and Senna was horrible with
politics okay he just wasn't good with
politics so it hurt him all the time he
said it would you know say no you didn't
win this race no you cheated no you did
this all this stuff there just kind of
go against him to the point where he
almost walked away from the game and so
forget about I'm never gonna race again
right in there
how did you handle the politics side of
body building knowing if you fight
somebody you knocked me out you won the
match but in bodybuilding it doesn't
matter how do you play that part of it I
didn't do well with that
because I come from I won't say the
streets but I come from you are who you
are you know I come from if you you
stare at a person too long they're gonna
look at you like what's up and you say
in return what's up but you there's no
more words you walk towards each other
and you're fighting that's it yeah so
that was really difficult for me because
in magazines you know guys would say
derogatory things about you and me and
my my adolescence I would want to go and
hurt him I mean you can't get away with
talking about a kid down the street
because he's gonna come holler at you
y'all heard you said something about me
now you gotta fight so for me to hear
and read people say certain things about
me in a magazine and its global so I'm
like wow these people probably think I'm
a punk and if they know that I'm was
okay fighter they gonna think this guy's
really tough cuz he's mouthing off so I
didn't handle it well at all and then as
far as magazines they were pretty hard
back then you know dating oh he looked
as smooth as a baby's a SS it was very
very straightforward I don't want to go
and hurt him you know that was my
thought so I didn't do well with it you
know a few meetings and and
I didn't do well because I didn't know
how to play the game I thought you just
respected by your merits of being a real
man it's not like that business isn't
like that globally it's not like that
but at that time coming from Fresno and
me being skinny Kenny inside I just
didn't see it didn't see it so you know
I wore my my film is on my sleeve you
know I'm very emotionally driven so if
you hurt my feelings I'm gonna let you
know it tears are becoming on my eyes
and I remember having to say to a lot of
guys hey I can't control these but I can
control these here and you about to find
out so they look at you think oh your
your woods you're crying like I can't do
nothing about these but I can do
something with these so you know so yeah
it really hurt me and I look back at it
and I just know I'm okay with it
I am Who I am you know for me I have to
be able to go home and look at myself in
the mirror and say you still a man you
know I I couldn't believe in selling out
for something more and being able to go
back and say yeah you're still a man
because for me or not you're not a man
if you sell yourself short or you got to
be phony in some but in front of
somebody's face or even with Ronnie
people like do you regret telling Ronnie
all the secrets I'm like for one they
weren't secrets or talk to me I go but
how can I sit him consider myself a real
champion what I know that I didn't tell
them everything I know and didn't do
battle with them I know that mm-hmm
you know he has some some some art early
that he doesn't ought to use so no I
don't regret it I want to compete
against the best and if you get me great
see you next time you know we're gonna
go at it but I just I'm not worried that
way I can't and if that means that I
can't be number one or the best or the
most Richardson I rather you know I'd be
ready to be me then they're not you know
I've talked to Phil I've talked to Dori
and I've talked to Ronnie and I've
talked to Brandon curry
yeah on Disney not any of you yeah so
you know you know questions I asked yeah
and and I'm more because I run a
business this is entrepreneur channel
I've only done five bodybuilding videos
we got 1,100 videos they're all business
and other things and I appreciate you
even giving I love some sport thanks
yeah I'm a fan of this sport I'm a big
fan of this sport but I also look at and
I say you know somes got to change
because if it goes like this I don't
know
how many more times you're gonna be able
to afford to do the events at the
arena's that you're doing that if you go
the way you're going there's got to be
something creative taking place how do
you see the world of bodybuilding today
versus a decade ago versus the era that
you came out of what is the biggest
difference um one of the biggest
difference I see is ability to generate
money the ability to generate money
before it was Joe Joe Weider he was the
only one who was handing out contracts
and he pretty much had at least 20 of
the greatest bodybuilders of all time
under his table and it was amazing and
then came along all the other supplement
companies and it started to get Friel
they didn't have to offer money anymore
to the greatest they started doing
things like I'll give you a product of
course you gonna give me a product you
want me to use it so they start doing
that and that started causing division I
think amongst athletes because for an
athlete like myself I'm trying to feed
myself and take care of my family this
isn't fun you know people get mad at me
like even during what say you know how
could you say that I'm like no I do this
for money it ain't a sport man I pay my
bills with this this is my job I
wouldn't be doing this if I couldn't
make money so that is really fragile
things I think the internet is a
double-edged sword it's beautiful
because you can go out and you don't
have to pay was it like 20 grand for an
ad you can advertise yourself yup for
free so but the other part of it is is
you know you can falsify things camera
angles you know Photoshop that they have
now with digital cameras and all that
stuff so you can be make-believe also
which I still think is the craft because
it's open to everyone so I don't you
know a lot of people get upset with them
what they call the youtubers or the
instagramers or whatever that phil is
open for everybody go down is to even
Phil get out you know so I'm not mad at
them now that you have all the various
different federations I think it's
really took a change and there's some
things that are happening in a
background that I can't say
but is really going to shake sport to
its core
on the upside of it a great thing that's
about to happen next year actually this
year is the rocks gonna put on his event
in Atlanta and I think with his his love
for the sport which I've talked to him
privately
back when he was wrestling he just loves
working out you can see it in his videos
do take a gym everywhere all over the
world I mean he loves it more than I do
yeah a lot more than I do so I think he
good for the sport he's great for he's
great for the sport because I remember
back in Arnolds days chevrolet and ESPN
were all their responses even during my
era ESPN was a sponsor we're on TV
national network you don't get that
anymore so there's not a draw there's no
ability to make money and at the end of
the day if you don't water the grass is
going to die and I just don't think the
sport was watered the way it possibly
could have marking it as everything you
know it's interesting that you can have
a little cartoon dog that looks like
this but me walking around like this is
not viewed at as good but your kid can
play with a toy that looks identically
like me that's a marketing problem you
got to market that better you know and
switch that around because it's
acceptable right we all seen it he-man
Shira they're all basically walking
images of us but us walking around can't
get on TV that way so that's a marketing
problem that I think filled through so I
think with the rock and his power and
everything that he's bringing can truly
upside to sport and bring back where
there's money in a sport and my last
thing on that is you know when you want
to be the best in the world it doesn't
have anything to do it health it don't
has to do with being the best in the
world now if I want to take boxing at
ain't gonna say a gyms name and give
them any props but I want to take boxing
at a gymnasium guys that's healthy right
cardio box and it's not another fighting
Mike Tyson that's not healthy it's not
it's not gonna be able T it's not gonna
end well that's the difference between
just doing something and trying to be
the best in the world
okay if I want to go jogging great good
for you
did you see the guys at the Olympics
their projectile puking while I run it
you think they're healthy
no they puts in her body styling it has
nothing to do with health so there's a
difference between trying to be the best
in the world and just doing something
for health reasons or whatnot I'm an
extremist and you know I tried to be the
best at what I can do but it can be
market a certain way and it has to be a
difference in that so hopefully it
swings back around and and gets better
because I truly feel that working out is
the essential to every sport I've got to
go play basketball and be a better
bodybuilder they got to come into gym to
be better at their karate
interesting point I've got to play
football or interesting pond gotta run
track I've got a hit it's when I swim I
don't gotta had to have a tennis racket
they all got to come into my world to
get better so how can we not be the
beginning crazy flex what you just said
how can I not who's selling it that way
what you just said right now um I'm I've
always said that but I've never seen it
being sold so how can all these other
sports make millions yeah but they got
to come into my world to get better at
it but me and my world you don't have
been havin their world no and we don't
get the same accolade that they get
that's really SS backwards so so you
know what's crazy what you just said so
um III get into the financial business
and I decided to go into insurance so I
start selling insurance instead of
stocks bomb series 766 there but I'm I
decided to go insurance that's my niche
because you're looking at at some point
of financial within your first two to
five years is gonna say money under
management you know stocks bonds mutual
funds commodities futures real estate or
insurance I sit insurance it's the
direction I want because everybody was
chasing everything here so I won this
set whatever you want I know all those
other ones they're gonna need insurance
that's exactly don't have to be in one
of those other ones that's exactly right
so I went into insurance and in the
insurance side I want to looked at
everybody how they told a story I said
that the stories not being told properly
about insurance it's just not being told
properly then we started telling the
story in a different way than the
industry was saying then all of a sudden
boom we go from zero thirteen thousand
agents Arkin
tensions we just had a few months ago
President Bush's at the event Kobe's
there we got 7,000 people there Adam Jim
we're about to do it at the mgn that one
was at Mirage Kevin Hart was that or
even a year ago year and a half ago
performing comedian at the top of his
world we told the story in a different
way I don't think today body buildings
being sold properly I don't know the
ownership personally I want you to know
I've been reached out by some of the
management team and we're having some
conversations but I don't know the
ownership team of the mr. Olympia brand
but either they have to sell 51% or
bring somebody to start selling this
thing to team up and bring in business
people the right voice the right face
doing something to the game for him to
change or else very soon
either mr. Olympia is gonna go become
lower and lower why would I put my body
through for $400,000 you're not gonna do
it there you go you're a rock gonna take
it over or eventually an Arnold will get
more attention classic I just think
there's got to be something done to the
mr. Olympia brand because like you said
today everybody else has to come to your
world you don't have to come to their
world now who's today's Joe Weider by
the way I would say there is no
replacement for Joe no there's no
there's no entity that is giving kids an
opportunity to make a living in their
sport without having to go out and work
a nine-to-five on top of it there's no
one who's doing it at the level Joe did
he was the Alpha and Omega of that and
and now understanding business and being
a hind behind it he lost money every
year who they Joe did Joe did lost money
every year well Pete and he put so much
and he put so much into the Olympia that
he literally lost money every year but
it was just passion in his love for the
sport that's a story of Enzo Ferrari
that's the story you know Walt Disney
that's the story of any of these guys I
mean if you look what the it's it's
short time thinking versus marathon
versus a sprint that's right and they
weren't thinking sprint Joe never
thought sprint he always wanted a sport
in Olympics I actually didn't want to be
an Olympics and I was against it because
you I was wrong okay
I sort of wanted a sort of whispered
because yeah you're an amateur and you
don't make any money but the money you
can make after that I was just thinking
short Olympics
exactly I was thinking short-term
because I leave money now I don't want
to compete in the show and put my
thought my body through the abuse and
and then hopefully someone like me and
market me so you know I wanted immediate
gains and gratifications because I had
immediate bills and you know so on good
point
but that's no that's not a replacement
so there's no there's no replacement or
there's nobody like him no one like okay
so let's you say we can replace some
fear but it could be done okay it could
be now are there personalities like him
right now that you would say if wanted
like like like let me give you some
names on what I'm saying okay like Bill
Phillips loved body built on one point
yeah yes you know he was good with the
whole contest promoter he was a market
about what Bill Phillips is a ridiculous
marketer you know that he is so Arnold
was a great storyteller oh my God look
at his muscle I've never seen the
separation like this before any hear his
voice right it's passionate like he
looks at you know buys it yeah this
guy's but so you were kind of like
wanted to impress the guy because it's
got to be a personality to do that sure
is there anyone that we don't know about
that maybe you know in your world to say
if that guy really wanted to come out or
if this guy wanted to come out he could
do something maybe a prima strollin pure
me somebody else how did a - you
mentioned it would be Arnold and I think
he hasn't been allowed to I've heard
conversations that he wanted to make the
prize money more and wasn't allowed to
for various different reasons I think he
he'd super exceeded that by having I
forget how many over 20 more sports than
the Olympics now he's achieved that a
different way
mm-hmm I won't say that me and Arnold or
friends were really close I remember you
know going into the Nike store and he
was there and I'd want to thank the Ohno
twice I don't believe in impeding on
people's private space especially
somebody like Arnold so I I was walking
around them he's like hey folks what you
doing and gave me a big hug senator
talking to me long story short I'm about
to pay for my clothing and he's getting
his for free
he's just signing you know and he goes
you know and he's very I don't know if
you ever talked very quick wit I mean
wow he's quick
you'll flex what are you doing I go Pam
for my stuff you guys know what are you
doing so I think he's about to go and
joking I go I'm paying you know what
you're paying for my stuff you pay for
it on he goes no seriously what are you
doing go I know I'm paying for my [ __ ]
and he looks at the lady he cusses her
out he said get to manager down here
right now
and manager came down you notice is this
bla bla bla bla bla bla
you got jeez god doggone football
players and basketball players you get
my free Gary you have any idea who this
guy is
take it threw the stuff back and walked
out and right then I understood what his
guys coming from this sport gave him
everything he came here a spore gave him
everything he believes in his sport
hence the reason why he puts on one of
the greatest competitions in a world
he's trying to better because it gave
him everything everything he done
spawned from this board and I understood
him fully in his inner-city youth gangs
that uh that he goes and he's involved
in he invited me to come and speak it
when it owes and award some incredible
words on a picture that he gave me so he
identifies it at the underdog a nobody
you know like he wrote in his book he
was beat up by his older brother and his
dad didn't like him because he thought
is a weakling you know so I get that
whole entire thing so I think he has
tooken brought steps to try to change it
even talking about the bloated guts and
how embarrassing it is and I think that
made some changes to following year but
anyone else you know not even on the
radar not on the radar if nothing I am I
not not am I now if nothing happens if
nothing changes what would you foresee
happening to the Brandon next 5-10 years
I don't I don't really see it a sport
dying because like I said it's the
essence of everything I see an opening
for people like the rock or people who
may have a greater global appeal being
and coming in and settling down and
doing something great with it because
it's a winner you know like you said you
tell the story properly it's the truth
you can't connect down I mean you got
people who don't even give a damn about
doing anything but they come into my
world mm-hmm
there's more of them than anybody do the
guys that mr. Olympia call you did they
call you to talk to you did they call
you for counsel the guys that are
running the straw
your ownership team you know CEO cm are
you talking to those guys no so you you
got out of your surgery that you had in
the last time of year
Oh they um a few a few reached out to me
a few reached out to me through other
people it was people were aware that I
was in a coma and I was in a hospital
for four three months so when I came to
the Olympia they throw out the red
carpet gave me a VIP table set me right
up in front and everything and I was
beautiful and they were really gracious
you know and since this happened
actually the the new person who took
over the Olympia actually came to the
hospital and visit me after respect
respect remitted to medicine he sends me
messages you know flex you you know same
thing I think you're gonna change the
world based on what you are going
through now and your mindset and you
know this ability a mode that took over
mr. Olympia that yeah Dan yeah okay
that's that's great to get yeah it's
really great to you for that to be take
and when Dan of always been close he was
axiom he was one of the major influences
on me getting the Ben reader Lifetime
Achievement Award two years ago and he
was the one who actually handed it out
to me on stage so he's always been
really nice so a lot of the independence
Jim Mannion I reached out to Robin
trained his a friend of mine said hey
looked like snow if he needs anything
let me know
that's great to hear yeah Delores who
puts on you on her class yeah we stopped
and said you know flex embody
Bloomington community is behind you you
know we love you I want to buy two
artists my special guests so he's bring
me out to dinner classic and he goes you
get a VIP service everywhere and I want
you to hand out the overall IFBB
wheelchair award so yeah beautiful
support beautiful support from our
community and I graciously appreciate it
I I think that's very important to do to
the alumni because that makes me want to
represent the brand knowing they take
care of the guys in the past who brought
so much exposure to it it's a very smart
phone any unique Joe Weider stories you
have any any experiences would joy
yourself yeah I mean so I was a bit of a
hothead and you know combat it and I
remember getting on the cover of flex
magazine a lot and plaques Mac flex
magazines all over the world
and other magazines covers all over the
world but I never got a muscle and
fitness cover and never never no and I
remember talking to Joe us like Joe I'm
like you know how come I can't you know
good a cover on Muscle & Fitness he goes
flexing and I think he was truly being
brutally honest you know he said flex if
I put you on a cover I'm gonna lose
money I could what do you mean by that
he goes I said I'm on covers of various
if four magazines all over the world he
goes well my logic is all over the world
you're not intimidating they don't see
you that often you know they don't see
black out athletes that often he goes
here in United States
you're more intimidating so if I put you
on a cover you know I feel that I'm
gonna lose money he flat out told you
that yeah and I said well I said you
know Joe I'm like you know yes there's
some brothers that got money too I don't
want to buy a magazine to see somebody
that looks like me on there and he goes
okay flex I'll do this I'll put you in a
cover if I lose money you pay me back to
money I lost if I make money
I'll share the money Ryan said no he
goes exactly he goes exactly I can't
take that risk so but what's he a guy
you trust it with you guys I do I I do
and I recognize the trials and
tribulations he was going through and
now I really recognize a financial
strain that it caused him and I owe
everything to him if it wasn't for that
man you know who created this board and
poured so much into I know where I'd be
right now and and I preached it that was
a lesson I get it more now than I did
and I even said I said Joe you know
you're you know you're Jewish you know
you know how hard it is you know to be
and he said yeah I am he goes that's why
I can't take that gamble you know go but
you can be the first of it I'm anything
he goes already offered you a deal take
it or leave it and it had to say
negotiator yeah I'm non-stop negotiator
yeah you know the way I look at it is it
may be in a different
you can challenge me on this I think you
have a certain level of wisdom others
don't have access to and that's why
sometimes guys like you become the
greatest coaches of all time and mentors
of all times and advisors of all time
and you never know why this happened
like why did I get dealt this hand man I
could have been like why are you doing
this to me God like put me out of this
flippin misery like why are you taking
me here and then but what is this all
about what is your and then sometimes
it's it's it's a bigger story and you
don't know what it is because it is like
you know for me I don't know why I lived
a life I live am I having a kid that's
gonna be a president one day what are
you doing why are you putting me through
this stuff that I experienced with the
war so then I have to kind of sit back
and say well just reverse impatient
maybe there's something going on here
and you gain a certain level of lens
that another person that doesn't have
that if you run into the next flex you
can give him direct and he has to take
it from you because you have moral
authorities so he knows you're not
coming from a place of motive you're
coming from a place of wanting to give
direction because I'm a big Tupac guy I
don't know if you're a guy of course I
am big or die hard to parkour
it was use as change September 23rd 96 I
don't know when it was when it when he
passed away but for me I think about it
what if somebody else was in that guy's
ear when he was younger what if there
was somebody else that was you know
speaking to him behind closed doors it
was all a negative yeah Antonia Brown
has somebody else in his ear what if it
was another person like even as a father
with his agent today I don't know if you
saw what he did or not it's agent
terracotta he says I can't do it on till
you decide to change yourself so his own
agent so what if somebody's in Tupac's
ear Tupac could have been a political
figure today doing rallies so so I look
at you and I see it I see life just
getting started if you're able to
channel your wisdom because that's not
what that's that's not only worth
millions of dollars that you can't you
can't buy this it's it's a certain level
of social capital experience that
somebody has to extract out of you if
you were to sit down with somebody and
say listen let me just tell you here's
the flaws and you seem like you're in a
place where you're willing to talk of
course I understand
value their flex priceless the value
there then you got a Tyson story I put
you Tyson there's certain stories there
that look thank you yes that's
incredible for you to say I really
appreciate that um yeah I I believe
everything like I said before what
happened for a reason and you know even
to you know the amputee and everything
that just happened a few months ago I
think they're all blessings you know I I
understand it but it's nice to rehear it
because you know from just just millions
of fans you know when this happened it's
like you know God on he goes his
greatest battles to history I guess
warriors so it's tough those are
big-time fights but I rather take on
those so I greatly appreciate what
you're doing in AMA I'm actually trying
to home in those skills now a number of
things that me and dr. Rees are doing
now to try to home and else because it's
it's for me it's more powerful giving
back I've had millions of had cars and
girls and houses and you know for me
because the way I'm worried those are
just big black holes they just suck up
and want more and more and more so you
know find that now and giving back and
it was various different ways whether
it's you know for me being you know
suicidal or depressed or any of these
battles that I have I think I've been
able to go through those battles they
turn around and hand them some lemonade
instead of lemons because life is gonna
do your lemons no matter what so my
thing is is if I can cope with these
lemons that I've given in life and turn
around and share a cup of lemonade with
you and serve it sweet then you don't
have to go through what I went through
you know and learn so that's just a
beautiful thing money can't buy that
you're right there are certain things
that you can do that just doesn't equal
to money because we both know major
millionaires and someone who are most
unhappy you know gutless worthless
people so what does that really mean you
know when you say that you know you have
millions or whatever you didn't tell me
anything actually told me a lot because
if that's the first thing that comes out
of your mouth you just told me you
piss-poor morally so you basically broke
so but I greatly appreciate that thank
you so much that's my observation man I
think you know is the guy sitting across
from me was an 18 year old kid who
admired you and looked up to your stuff
and I couldn't believe that you know a
human being can be created with this
perfect symmetry like this you know the
level of admiration a bunch of boys had
like me growing up I don't think I've
heard you fully comment on how you're
processing the whole you've been through
with different challenges in your life
health you know a car accident close
calls even life in that type of
situation I wanted them with your neck I
mean that was not a regular thinking and
now with this how different is this then
the other experiences you've had this is
the most challenging obviously you know
I've I've had probably I stopped
counting at like 60 surgeries so a lot
of them I didn't even come out and
public and talk about yeah yeah this is
uh it's interesting it's it's hard to
put into words you know it's it's
nothing that's altered my life greater
than this and I think you know you've my
doctors we're trying to be psychiatrist
and help me know return it you know
explain to me like this is gonna be a
lot tougher than to you for most people
because of where you come from and what
you've done but um it's it's emotional
rollercoaster you know it just changes
your perspective and everything I
remember doing a video and instead it's
different looking at things full foot
tall because when I'm in my wheelchair
I'm about 4 foot high and everything is
different you think about things that
you didn't have to how can I get to the
restroom you know in time you know being
in public and toilet sort of worst in
public you know what I have to carry
with me to make sure I'm ok with that
from watching a movie or from driving
you know how quickly can I get to a
bathroom just things you don't think
about getting yourself dressed all those
things but what would I take from it and
where I get my strength is you know I
was built for this
I was built for this I think every
battle that I had most men physically
was preparing me for this one and I
remember when I had to make the decision
for them to take it because like I said
you know it was a DVT that they found in
February and I was in a hospital
actually from March for like four three
months I was in a coma for ten days and
in the surgeries that they try to do to
save my leg I knew they weren't working
so I was just an extreme amount of pain
for the last you know five or six months
it was just ridiculous so I remember
going into the hospital after coming
from a trip actually would my business
partner and I called my wife and I was
like you know I think I need to go to
your when I get off the plane she's like
all right I'll meet you there
and they went in did an ultrasound and
said okay date came back like you know
on the right side of your calf is 90%
blocked and the left side is a hundred
percent you know and she just said you
know the flex nobody can make this
decision but you and I was like take it
let's just take it you know but um
anyway my point is is I don't I don't
feel that I was allowed to do all these
things on a global scale and then go and
hide when it's happened and that's why
before they even you know took my leg I
went on Instagram and I was talking
about it because I'm like you know I
want to be I want to be a spokesperson
for these people you know I want to be a
spokesperson for everybody who has
different disabilities because it's just
yeah you you just don't think about a
lot of things until you're there you
know and a lot of these people didn't
have my platform so you know I've
already discussed with my business
partner and open up a nonprofit
organization I want to help people get
wheelchairs and amputees and just bring
awareness and funds and all that stuff
and you know it's not about the money
thing for me it's just um it's rough you
know when you have and I didn't
understand it to be honest with you
because I made to call and I was fine
with it I was doing videos and
I was in hospital I told myself I said
when I wake up after they take my leg
soon as I look down if I'm okay wait
I'll be all right
if I freak out I'm having a bad fight
when I woke up I was like I'm okay with
this it was only until I got home and I
woke up the next morning at my house I
have stairs in it and uh and it just
like like the devil just was having his
way with me just a horrible thought
sighs well last time I was in my home I
had two legs you know looking at the
staircase and you never really look over
the staircase you look at the stairs
because you walking up and I walked to
my balcony I looked over the stairs I'm
like Jesus if I fall you know it's just
fear every time I go up and down my
stairs I'm in fear because if I fall
it's not gonna be good
every picture in my house every thing
that I bought it had two legs and I come
back down and it just really just wore
me out and I just had to tell myself
when I was really emotional and I was
sitting there what my wife and she was
trying to console me and she kind of
backed up she said you know what I don't
even know what you're going through so
she just went silent and I said you know
baby I'll be okay I go but if I really
want to sit in front of someone who's
going through or went through something
that I went through I got to go through
this I got it to go through the hills
and the bowels of it deeply if I'm gonna
sit in front of somebody else and try to
help them and pull them out of this
darkness goes every dark comes to you
suicide you're less than a man you're
half a man you know you're not worthy
all those things so I'm like I really
have to deal with every ounce of emotion
oh garbage to be able to truly sit in
front of somebody and help them if not
they're gonna see I'm faking I'm gonna
lose them you know so I really I really
take it on as a blessing I mean I want
to be long winded but I really need to
say this you know in his picture all the
great things you said you would think
this guy just thinks he's pristine his
Shi T don't stink I was never happy
never like I told you I never walked on
stage and thought I was good enough
always uncomfortable
no matter what I wore what I dressed in
my car and my standing up straight
somebody looking at me ever
uncomfortable since first time I try to
commit suicide when I was 11 or 13 never
comfortable for the first time in my
life I'm fully comfortable don't bother
me I don't hide it as powerful and so
for me it's a blessing because the man
upstairs loved me enough to bless me
with this blessing so that I can be
happy I rather live ten more minutes the
man I am now then another fifty four
years of the person I was there so it's
a beautiful thing and I'd be oh I can
help people who really freaking need it
you know because you you always look at
him I wonder what's your story and I see
people looking at me do look at me kind
of like with pity or sorrow and I'm like
I'm gonna happy as men in a room right
now you just don't understand you know
so it is rough and even today just the
first time get on the airplane
terrifying you know and I actually got
emotional because I went to the bathroom
and just to be able to use the toilet
and have to stand on one leg and it's
not another when I got back to my seat I
was just shook and you know just a lot
of first-time experiences terrified what
if plane goes down how am I gonna get
out of here normally on the first person
on you know one of the first people on a
plane and first person off how'd it be
last this time just a lot of things you
know so it isn't a most emotional roller
coaster but I take it on with pride
because I know I'll be able to do some
people a great service I think the level
of impact you can make make a moving
forward is going to be much bigger than
the impact you made so far you know I've
heard that so many times and I I do
believe it but you know to to hear
something that you already filled or
know by other people kind of reinstates
you're filling in I truly hope so
because I don't I tell my kids this all
the time
I don't want to be known as flex wheeler
the body builder who gives it down
you're just an athlete that doesn't
serve your worth come on we know plenty
of people who are millionaires
billionaires athletes and their garbage
I'd only be known as an athlete I just
want to be known as a person who was
decent who tried
helped other people you heard what Phil
he'd said he says not flex wheeler the
bodybuilder but flex wheeler don't man
yeah so so for a guy like that to say
that yeah and and and phil is also
pretty prop right he's very proud of who
he is as well for him to say something
like that it's very powerful so some of
the things I'm up to now would as came
to the table it's like you know just to
pain I'm I'm in pain 24 hours a day even
now it never goes away
not only the amputee I have no Rob at
the end my leg in my hand so it was just
it's just unspeakable pain so I've been
trying all these various different
things and in a hospital of course I
haven't drug me out of my brain just to
keep me out of pain but once I came home
I'm like I can't do that I got on my
brain you know it just can't be a zombie
so I've been reading up in hearing about
CBD O's and I've been trying a number of
different ones so I have the tremendous
opportunity of coming out with my own
line of CB do is to help people just for
the pain that they're going through and
stuff like that again like we talked
about earlier because now I'm being an
amputee I'm looking at things different
just a comfort of a wheelchair and being
able to get around so I'm gonna release
in my online of a wheelchairs called a
flex chair so electric phones is the
most compact and powerful wheelchair
that's out there in the market right now
we're in a process of devising a blood
clot dinner so I lost my leg due to
blood clot that comes along with a lung
or a slew of different other things so
right now with my nutrition company that
were open up that's called iconic
supplements from the one picture but um
those one of the things we're working on
so a lot of various different things you
know got a tour in Pakistan that I'm
looking forward to tour in India and
those are some of my first tours and I'm
good and doing so I'm just trying to
open back up to the world I am available
to start travelling so more so than
anything I just trying to create
different business adventures that
actually help people more than you know
myself because of so many things I've
been through so some exciting times you
know we respect you for doing that what
we're gonna do is we're gonna put the
link below for all three of them you can
go click on a link below to find out
more information
we'll also put all your social media
everything to be able to follow on this
wall so 2020 predictions any you think
feel you think I you think these road
and you think these guys are gonna come
back and compete 2020 after brand new
curry winning I don't know I don't think
I don't think Kai will cuz he's doing so
much finance he better
and I've actually told Kai you know why
would you ever come back you know you
you're gonna come back to allow certain
people to have power over you when you
have endless power globally now and you
have nothing to gain financially from it
he's so financially strong feel I don't
know I think he easily come back and be
at its best in and and when aid and
possibly nine he still has it in him as
an athlete I don't know if he has an
enemy as a person because I know he's
switching over business-wise and I
haven't talked to him about this but I
just from his interviews and stuff that
I see he's doing I think he's
understanding I can make just as much or
more money not having to go through the
hill that I look great you know continue
looking great continue training but I
don't have to take it to that level of
going on stage and I can make more money
than that and if you can then why would
you continue doing that and honestly it
just takes a certain mind frame that we
have when were younger to go through
hell and enjoy it
you know it's like having a lower court
that's but you look good mm-hmm as a
gentleman I don't a car like that I want
something nice comfortable you know so I
don't know if he had that ability to go
back and hurt the way he needs to hurt
the wind you don't know if he I don't
know if he has that in him anymore you
know and it's not to say that he's not a
fighter but you just you have to
understand competing at that level it's
not going to be fun there's nothing fun
about it you know it looks great he has
talent wise can he do it of course he
could talent wise can kya come back and
wife everybody forward everybody of
course you could but it's
is whether you want that fighter and and
on top of that whether maestro limp your
brand wants them back what are they
gonna do for them to want to come back
because they got to make it juicy for
them to honor
yeah cuz they don't make more money
doing a couple of parents as scores and
not even having to take it to the next
level of diet and and everything else
that comes in detail with it so I got to
do this since I've been doing this but I
know I know you know well enough so yeah
I let's go through it so everyone's been
brave to give their feedback and to put
that adjective in there to kind of raise
you know I know you what we discussed
this already the reason why you know so
he spit up in the back like a signal up
hey man you know we talked about so so
what would you say with these guys
versus your era you've heard Ronnie
you've heard Dorian well I got Dre on
there defusing I'm switching me I know
you are but alright I come back okay um
what's your question so these guys
compared to you compared to your era I
mean I got to be honest no no you know I
mean I competed with two of them and
Dexter out of except Brandon Dexter was
the first to win Olympia and when we
competed on the same stage I think I was
like first and he was like tenth you
know so it was just different
yeah where would they what would this be
in your era you saw what Ronnie and
Dorian said where would they rank would
they compete with the you would with you
guys of somebody Sean ray LeBron Cormier
would they compete with those guys no I
would have to probably say no not like I
just demonstrated
you know Dexter didn't throw that world
against us
no it's just kind of it's just kind of
different you know no no I mean any
disrespect to these gentlemen I know all
of them and I consider myself you know
very cordial with all of them it's not a
personal
you know and I can't laugh about it
because it's not funny but you're being
honest among men who are working really
hard but no it's it's different and I
think if you were to ask any of those
gentlemen they were probably city saying
do you think it's fair for Roli the
argument he made he says it's kind of
unfair for the old-timers to go at brain
and curry and say what they're saying
this is a different error kind of like
you know how the great basketball you
can agree with because you know it's
about getting your point across but not
being harsh there's no need to be harsh
or malice or hurt a person's feeling you
know so that's why I'm being very
cordial and persuasive with my words and
stuffs any idea they can compete it with
their garb it's known isn't in a
Champions it's just a different air and
it's not fair to compare them because
we're not in that era and you know what
doesn't matter because this men right
here and this one now right here has
Olympia's and I don't so who gives it
down right because they are miss
Olympians I know go down as known as mr.
Olympia so what difference does it make
they won mr. limpy's in air so they're
the best out there their craft during
that time and definitely Rolly is
definitely considered one of the best I
mean it's amazing I want to say this
because he gave me one of the greatest
comments ever you know it was a video
and he said you know I think if I want
to be anybody build in a world I'd be
flex he was just flawless if I could be
anybody I'd be him and for Rowley to be
as massive and in shape and to say that
I just had to send him a message like
wow man thank you that is Wow that's
cool yeah so and by the way brain and
curry
I got to tell you what a classy guy a
hundred you know what a percent last guy
just came here you know I'm like in the
way he handled it because that pressure
and yeah who wants to do that after you
just wanna come in and I'm like you know
seen his interviewed I even see this
interviewed after with Dorian said yeah
to me I think he gained respect I'm not
real points on who's the greatest all
this I think he gained was a man and a
person I think he gained respect I've
been knowing Branden forever accident
when he was an amateur I was covering
him and I gave him a nickname so brother
number one so brother number one is if
you look he looked like a character from
shaft or something like that right
so what he's been able to do in his his
vision and his thought and self-belief
and himself paid away from the video man
he is now in a champion we're at the end
of it I got the couple things I'm gonna
show you I'm gonna show you a video here
and then I'll do speed run and we'll be
done okay so if when you see these
pictures what do you think about trying
to be like Prince trying to be like
pretty women yeah I mean so you were a
prince Kuo yeah yeah hundred percent
only concert I ever went to in my entire
life to this day Prince how are you on
the right just a kid who's trying are
you 20 or you good 20 I'm 20 yeah I
think that's after I want a cow so yeah
I'm about 22 there 22 23 just I just
look at that kid and said you know you
have no idea what's ahead of you son you
know feel bad for you in some ways and
good for the other only concert you've
been in his prints I cut that that's
pretty attic the only one you've ever
been a man to study mr. Michael Jackson
performer nah never got to see him
perform so - you know Michael James like
I never watch Michael play Michael
Jordan I never watch Michael Jackson
perform mhm but Prince is one of the
legendary performers of all time so what
do you think well when you see this guy
just innocent man I won my first honor
classic and I had no idea love what he'd
even met I just I just know what the
check was that's it it's what you do
afterwards this night I went to my room
and ate pizza that's it yeah just one
egg pizza and that was it you know a way
to celebrate yeah and I had to forget
about I remember telling myself that's
who gives a damn you know you got it so
next weekend you're gonna get the floor
mop which if you want to party about
what you did a few hours ago did this
picture this doesn't make any sense to
me when I see this picture of you like I
know it's probably not the this picture
is like you know this this looks like a
statue with the with the with the diff I
mean that's just insane right I don't
know how I do that because I didn't know
anything about dieting I didn't know
anything about dieting whatsoever Paul
what do you think about this when you
see this just go home and cry
this one is a classic one that's doing
bad on man three of the greatest of all
times and we were just deeply friends we
had tremendous respect for each other
but man we try to take each other's head
off on stage and then hugs and smiles
afterwards any any stories of Kevin we
don't know about any Union given I said
it before Kevin you know we had a lot of
respect for each other
he beat me in the Nationals he turned
pro before I did and I hated him for it
and I chased him and I end up beating
Matt at the first Honor classic and back
then it was his magazines and he would
always be mouthy in a magazines and all
that and he said flex I hear you knock
but you can't come in I said you know
for Kevin I don't knock on doors I knock
him over watch out you know so we just
it was all beef talk I mean when we got
together was nothing but mutual respect
which is a husband for guys it's great
it made us tremendous tremendous
tremendous I think I think I think a lot
of you I don't know personality was what
how he is but Hollywood you know a lot
of good-looking guys he could have been
a yeah what it is you know a lot of
these guys you see right now that are
bodybuilders and they're fighters and
they're movies now because they had
physiques there's a lot of guys that are
doing that yeah yeah you know there
could have been some opportunities there
for him this video here okay I'm nervous
but when you when you think about movies
hammer you know and movies day day
there's all these body but there's all
these mr. Olympius but in this movie
they quote you I mean it's it aren't you
John keel
[Music]
it was amazing actually the director of
the movie was the brother of one of my
trainers so in that movie
remember Denzel got shot mm-hmm one of
my trainers was a person who shot him in
the movie in a movie and his brother was
the director of the movie so how that
happened was he was training his brother
and then I would train afterwards and
sometimes he would hang over in watts
and after about a year his brother said
wow you guys are amazing I got to give
tribute to you guys somehow the hard
work you just just look at you you don't
think of that and then he came back and
he asked me goes flex how this movie can
I use your name and likeness and I'm
like yeah sure they asking before they
yeah yeah yeah yes brother did and I
just I couldn't believe because I'd been
to a croc Siddhant so I was eager to
watch the movie and it started off with
that horrific car accident just in a
grab me because I'd been through so and
I have a son I have two sons so the what
wouldn't you do for your so the movie
just hooked me it wouldn't let me go
yeah yeah amazing but um it's just
beautiful man just again you know they
ended by you know saying just to be you
know accept it for your craft and what
you've done and not viewed whether
you're black or white or straight or gay
or anything I think everybody know we'll
just writing to do that in their various
different ways so to be respected that
way and somebody think I have some
Southworth's or value is just from this
little kid that come from the ghetto in
Fresno is just you know how many posters
you've been on how many walls you've
been on man like how many kids like
that's not just a movie scene man that's
like real life times millions this last
one here I want since we're doing this
this is your guy and here's what he says
about you okay once you what you think
about when you listen to this what's
crazy about flicks body use them as one
of the greatest bodybuilders ever ever
yeah everybody yeah yeah me too who your
top five yeah I got Arnold
I got me I got feel flex and Kevin a
head of durian like you wouldn't put the
Flex no
I got affected ahead of me what's the
biggest difference well from Kevin and
flexus physique but I can I better shape
get better shape yeah I think like that
better shape than me a good contact way
no flicks yeah my bitrate of the world
yeah
just was text them yes so he just had
surgery again can't believe it you know
again like I said I don't think anyone's
ever gonna be would Ronnie brought to
the table they might beat his um his
number but they you can't take the best
of all time picture and Matt sit up
against him and be defeated and we just
always hit it off we were always friends
and and our friendship really truly was
tested when he turned her on and beat me
for the first time because that's when
he find out was really going on right
and we just stayed the test of time and
I just want to give him a shot all he
just had hip replacement again you know
just just a day and uh and we talked you
know we both been through some
extraordinary pain and I'm like man I'm
bleeding for you guys no it's okay you
know it's okay he goes I still haven't
caught up to you and your surgeries I'm
like you don't want that record he
doesn't know I don't because I don't
want that record so Wow
he's he's another humble guy here's a
guy that can be cocky just a humble guy
yeah that you did she like quick quick
speedrun I'll give you some names some
of the reason that comes to mind Ennis
James
true friend mother well he sent me the
link he says Pat I watch your interviews
here's what we're doing for Soltan what
the GoFundMe and that's when we put and
we supported but he was just so yeah
he's the one that reached out nobody
Dennis is the one I don't know if you
know this you need to know it I did and
then it send a message and then we
shared it or else Wow Wow one word
Dorian Yates
just competitive you know during his era
on stage unbreakable unbreakable yeah
Lee Priest Wow Lee jack of all trades
and a master of many in a master of many
yeah
Paul delet didn't get his due just if he
was competing now he would be
unbreakable on stage there will be
nobody can do anything about a sting
yeah very interesting yeah
natural Samadhi tremendous friend I
remember the first time competing
against him when he turned pro and just
tragic loss to our support Aaron Baker
God Batman the true Batman it always
broke my heart
Aaron was top 10 in the world and he
always had to work two jobs I never got
a fair shake and I know he was always
upset about the ones so I beat him in
right after my car accident but just you
just have no idea how gifted that guy
was he could draw I remember him doing
fencing against pros and him and goes
gym parking lot just fencing fencing Wow
and they were gonna bring him on a team
wrestling everything just just amazing
yeah a true Batman
Cormier Wow
true friend when his strong his body
bows are ever trained what these strong
his body bit of ever trained with mess
with him I heard six plates on incline
yes I'm so messed with it don't mess
with him when it comes to China out Oh
trained him shot rate sunray jeez I
already gave it away what my facial
expression um you know tremendous
athlete very on top of his game as a
business person someone I looked up for
years and wanted to emulate and taught
me a lot in a sport safer you should run
for office at Nichols Wow
not sure what where I'd be without him
yeah taught me a lot in an age of gurus
he taught me that flex you know more
about you than me the only reason I can
help
if you understand your body well enough
to explain it to me that I can give you
advice what a way to put it yeah he's
like you're with yourself 24 hours a day
I'm not yeah Jay Cutler true champion
businessman great person love Malad
great guy great guy like methodical Mike
was a very close friend we traveled the
world together
just tremendous lost has broke my heart
I'm when he passed but man we had some
great battles together incredible
champion guys wrong with you you were
good on ESPN by the way - yeah yeah I'm
gonna beat you mr. California all this
stuff you guys were doing yeah it looked
like that's we're having fun Lee Haney a
man's man a champions champion you never
heard him say nothing bad about anybody
been married to the same woman since
high school
you don't hear nothing negative you in
every sport every business you hear you
never got nothing bad about him respect
just a champions champion Sergio Oliva I
met him before he pass and he was always
just an amazing person in force and just
to hear his story and my first Olympia
when I was going back into the hotel it
was him who open the door for me I was
like oh my god you know and he goes flex
you won that show don't let nobody tell
you different you won that show that's
like I don't care about that man I just
met you you know can I say can and now
I'm having honored to be friends you
know with his son who was just carrying
a torch from just yeah there's there's
people who are anchors in business or
sports or a life and he's truly an
anchor in our support brother this is
it's felt like five minutes but I think
it's been two hours I don't know exactly
what the times been it's got like five
minutes to me because the conversations
been just purely fascinating going
you know history with you I appreciate
you making a time to come out and
sitting down here with us and opening up
talking to us just sharing us with where
your hearts at and I hope all the
listeners that are listening in any
links that he has we're putting below go
send him some love whether it's on
Instagram I think your most active on
Instagram send them a message and if in
the future you ever want to come back to
talk any other bodybuilding any other
story man you're always open to come
back you're truly pleasure having you as
a guest
I appreciate you first and foremost it
takes people like you for even people
like me to be noticed so you know kudos
go to you first for even having
interested in our sport for even
thinking that I have anything of value
to talk to on your tremendous outreach
that you have so being able to sit here
in front of a person who comes from a
whole different background and him and
interest in me is just it's solidifying
it makes you feel you know you're worthy
so you know thank you so much in a time
and effort that you put in all this to
have such a premiere show it's what you
don't understand is what most people
don't understand is the honor is really
mine because I get to go to different
parts of the world and I'm just accepted
for me as a person and you know you've
been Persian and and all that you you
know what that's like I've been accepted
so again you know I'll end it with just
the honor is mine just to be accepted
for my strengths my weaknesses my
setbacks my shortcomings and all that is
just yeah I can never think people like
you you know enough who thinks that you
know I have something to offer so yeah
it goes back to you Tim full impact with
you is just getting warmed up man I'm
telling you it's just getting warmed up
and doc I gotta tell you thanks for
making us work as well I know we're
going back and forth flex appreciate you
man thank you so much thank you thank
you professor thank you so obviously you
saw myself in flex talk about dorian
yates as well as ronnie called a lot of
stories there so if you haven't yet
watched the ronnie coleman interview
click over here and if you haven't
watched the door eh of interview click
over here and if you haven't subscribed
to the channel please do so
everybody bye-bye
[Music]